bien mes chers collègues
afin d'échanger sur l'évolution du
secteur de la radio à l'heure du
développement de la radio numérique le
DAB plus je suis heureux d'accueillir ce
matin votre nom monsieur rock Olivier
Metz président de larcome Madame
constance banquet présidente du bureau
de la radio madame
présidente directrice générale de Radio
France Monsieur Christophe chalk
président du syndicat des radios
indépendantes et Monsieur Emmanuel
Boutrin qui doit nous rejoindre
qui doit nous rejoindre président du
Syndicat national des radios libres
comme le rappel régulièrement le
président de LARCOM la radio et le média
préféré des Français celui qui les
accompagne dans leur vie
quotidienne dès le matin et souvent en
tard le soir également c'est aussi un
média historique qui a joué un rôle
important dans notre vie démocratique
comme vient de le rappeler la
reconstitution il y a quelques jours de
la première diffusion de l'Appel du 18
Juin du général de Gaulle par un
logiciel d'intelligence artificielle les
nouvelles technologies sont en effet
devenues un enjeu important pour
l'avenir de ce média la radio est
aujourd'hui confrontée à la nouvelle à
la concurrence des nouvelles offres
comme les plateformes de musique en
ligne et les services de podcast elle
doit continuer bien entendu à ce
moderniser ce qui pose la question de
ces modes de diffusion l'AFM a montrer
sa pertinence depuis une quarantaine
d'années elle a permis l'éclosion de
nouvelles antennes sur tout le
territoire ainsi que la constitution de
grands réseaux écoutés par la jeunesse
mais cette technologie a également
montrée ses limites avec une qualité
d'écoute inégale une disponibilité des
fréquences insuffisantes et un coup de
diffusion important d'autres modes de
diffusion sont apparus comme l'IP et la
radio numérique qui apparaissent plus
homogène dans la qualité d'écoute
apporte davantage de services écoute
également moins cher en frais de
diffusion nous sommes bien conscients
des difficultés que rencontrent les
radios aujourd'hui avec une désaffection
de certains publics et un marché
publicitaire de plus en plus disputé par
les acteurs du numérique l'opérateur
public a pour sa part connu une baisse
en niveau d'essai moyen d'une vingtaine
de millions d'euros depuis 2018 alors
que les recettes des radios sont donc
orientées à la baisse leur poste de
dépenses ne sont pas épargnés par la
hausse des coûts c'est dans ce contexte
qu'intervient le développement du DAB
plus qui oblige de nombreux acteurs à
devoir financer une double diffusion à
la fois en FM et en date plus ce qui
n'est pas à la portée de toutes les
radios si nous avons souhaité vous
entendre ce matin c'est évidemment pour
connaître votre analyse de la situation
et comprendre la stratégie des acteurs
que vous représentez mais également pour
essayer de nous projeter à l'horizon de
2030 ou 2035 est-ce que nous devons
considérer que le DAB plus constituera
toujours d'ici là un mode de diffusion
complémentaire ou bien devant nous
partir du principe que la radio
numérique est appelée à se substituer à
l'AFM dans le premier cas le recours aux
dates plus de Murray un choix propre à
chaque acteur alors que dans le second
évidemment il reviendrait nécessairement
à l'état et au parle de demander à
l'arcom d'organiser une transition avec
comme perspective une extinction de
l'AFM si nous avons souhaité organiser
cette table ronde c'est aussi parce que
la stratégie des pouvoirs publics ne
nous semble pas suffisamment clair sur
ce sujet certes l'arcome poursuit le
déploiement du DAF plus qui devrait en
2023 couvrir la moitié de la population
métropolitaine mais il ne faut pas
confondre couverture des populations et
usages de cette technologie la plupart
des Français semblent
ignorer l'existence même de la radio
numérique qui pourtant s'impose dans les
voitures comme l'avenir de la radio la
France a pris du retard dans les
développements du DA plus mais cela ne
signifie pas qu'il ne sera pas
prochainement comblé faut-il dans ces
conditions développer une politique
publique ambitieuse afin d'accompagner à
la fois les radios pour qu'elle diffuse
en date plus mais également les français
pour qu'ils adaptent leur usage est-il
nécessaire
que l'État aide l'ensemble des acteurs à
engagé cette transition et avec quel
type de dispositif voilà quelques
questions quelques-unes des questions
que nous souhaitons vous poser sachant
que dans notre esprit c'est
l'appropriation par une très large
majorité de Français de cette
technologie qui pourra infiner poser la
question de la raie de la FM nous en
sommes donc assez loin je vais céder
maintenant la parole au président de
LARCOM afin qu'ils nous présente un bref
état des lieux du tape plus puis
évidemment chaque intervenant prendra
ensuite la parole pour s'exprimer notre
collègue Jean Raymond Hugonnet
vous poserez ensuite une première série
de questions puis évidemment chacun des
autres collègues qui le souhaitent
pourra vous interroger à son tour je
vous rappelle que cette audition est
captée et diffusée sur le site internet
du Sénat monsieur le Président de la com
je vous cède la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président ça va être un
grand plaisir qu'on se début d'année je
retrouve votre commission avec laquelle
nous travaillons très étroitement et en
confiance et j'allais dire très
activement compte tenu de
l'investissement du Sénat pardon
monsieur
si vous pouviez augmenter les micros le
son des micros
il faut que j'appuie sur celui
c'est meilleur là c'est bon
merci monsieur le Président donc je
disais combien nous étions heureux avec
Hervé gotcho membre du collège qui
m'accompagne
Frédéric bocopsa qui est directeur
général adjoint qui suit plus
particulièrement ce dossier et puis
François-Xavier melon quel directeur de
la radio et de l'audio numérique au sein
des services de l'arcom de retrouver en
ce début d'année votre commission avec
laquelle nous travaillons très
intensément sur les sujets audiovisuel
contenu de l'investissement de du Sénat
bien connu sur ces questions majeures
pour notre pour notre pays je vous
remercie également de votre initiative
de cette table ronde vous savez combien
ce média nous est cher à l'arcom mes
chers à titre personnel je dis souvent
que c'est le média du cœur et vous
l'avez dit dans votre propos c'est un
média qui est plébiscité par les
Français
40 millions de Français écoutent tous
les jours la radio un média de masse
très puissant et c'est surtout l'un des
médias auxquels les Français font le
plus confiance on croit ce qu'on entend
la radio peut-être parfois tort mais on
fait confiance à ce média ça ressort
très nettement de tout toutes les
enquêtes de pignons c'est un vecteur de
lien social très très important
et on l'a vu pendant la polémique
pandémie y compris au niveau local il
faut d'ailleurs tirer un coup de chapeau
radio associatif la fonction de service
de la radio est aussi une fonction très
très importante c'est en mettre en même
temps un média qui mérite notre
attention collective parce que il est
interrogé on le sait vous l'avez
souligné un marché publicitaire qui est
effectivement en tension il y a eu un
léger rebond en 2021 mais le marché
n'est pas aujourd'hui au niveau où il
était en 2019
donc c'est un point de vigilance parce
que c'est le financement de ce média qui
qui est en question et puis c'est un
média qui est également vraiment
supporté par des acteurs puissants je
pense notamment au secteur des radios
musicales avec le rôle des plateformes
de streaming qui joue maintenant qui ont
un poids très important mais on pourrait
citer bien évidemment le rôle des
réseaux sociaux qui comptent aussi très
important et puis les mesures d'audience
bien montrent tout de même quelques
points de vigilance même si on observe
de fortes disparités entre les acteurs
le service public je pense que la
présidente va y aura l'occasion de
l'évoquer montre qu'on peut aussi bien
tirer son épargne du jeu dans dans le
secteur mais ça doit être un point de
vigilance tout en relevant que c'est un
média qui a aussi comme toujours au fil
de son histoire des 100 ans de son
histoire une capacité de rebond
formidable du fait du capital qui est le
sien
d'abord en sachant s'adapter aux
usages et le mouvement du podcast qu'il
s'agisse de Replay ou de podcasts natifs
ouvre un nouvel horizon de même que les
transformations technologiques et j'en
viens très directement DAB+ sont une
perspective d'avenir importante pour ce
média et c'est la raison pour laquelle
depuis que je préside cette institution
l'arcom a souhaité donner un coup
d'accélérateur au déploiement du DAB+
puisque la France était en retard par
rapport ses voisins à la fois pour
construire et contribuer au futur de la
radio mais aussi en partant d'un constat
qui est la saturation et je le vois
quotidiennement saturation de la bande
de la bande FM il suffit de regarder à
chaque appel à candidature que nous
faisons sur la bande FM les choix
cornéliens auxquels nous sommes
confrontés et du coup l'activité
contentieuse qui est considérable
l'activité contentieuse de l'arcom la
radio occupe une place de choix parce
que bien évidemment il y a beaucoup
d'appelés sur les fréquences
éventuellement disponibles et très peu
d'élus puisqu'il y a très peu de très
peu de fréquences donc le DAB+ pour nous
est un chantier prioritaire d'abord
parce qu'il répond à l'intérêt du public
une qualité d'écoute supérieure
son numérique un incontestable confort
d'écoute en mobilité quand on a goûté au
DAB+ on a beaucoup de mal à le quitter
et pour utiliser des tronçons autour
utile sur la chance d'être couvert par
cette technologie j'en mesure à titre
personnel tout le tout le prix c'est une
technologie qui est économe en énergie
il faut le rappeler moins d'émetteurs
nécessaires pour pour couvrir le
déploiement
c'est un accès gratuit pour pour les
auditeurs donc il y a pas
d'intermédiation avec des acteurs tiers
c'est une technologie qui permet
d'enrichir l'offre par rapport à une
bande de FM
et c'est une technologie qui s'inscrive
dans le concert européen puisqu'on a
nombre de partenaires de l'Union qui
sont aujourd'hui
dans une phase active ou beaucoup plus
avancée que nous la Norvège la Suisse le
Royaume-Uni l'Allemagne la Belgique les
Pays-Bas l'Italie l'Espagne donc la
France ne peut pas rester telle une
tribu gauloise repliée sur son petit
village elle doit aussi prendre en
compte les perspectives donc vous l'avez
dit l'objectif pour cette année
c'est maintenant le couvrir 50% de la
population
je pense qu'on a franchi avec les
acteurs mais ils vont s'exprimer à notre
place qu'il soit public ou privé et je
les remercie parce que c'est un choix
structurant pour pour le secteur et un
choix qui a bien évidemment un coup
en terme de charge de diffusion mais je
crois que ce choix est maintenant fait
et définitivement fait et que maintenant
il faut réussir clairement cette cette
opération alors les prochaines étapes
pour nous c'est bien évidemment d'abord
de poursuivre le déploiement et
l'autorité s'est mise en ordre de marche
pour accélérer autant que faire ce peu
ces procédures alors les procédures sont
longues parce que bon
très familier du cadre législatif et
réglementaire qui est le nôtre on est en
France on aime bien les réglementations
dans ce dans ce pays et les
réglementations sont sont lourdes sont
contraignantes et on a beaucoup d'étapes
à franchir mais en tout cas sur la
feuille de route de déploiement du DAB+
on a mis le plus possible l'accélérateur
deuxième point qui nous paraît vraiment
crucial et on a beaucoup insisté
là-dessus je suis heureux que les
partenaires publics et privés étaient
enfin réussi à se mettre d'accord sur ce
point l'heure de la promotion du DAB+ et
devenu cruciale il faut faire connaître
le DAB+ aux Français je suis frappé même
quand il m'arrive de prendre un taxi à
Paris très souvent on écoute le DAB+
dans un taxi à Paris mais on ne sait pas
on est comme Monsieur Jourdan hum qui
faisait la preuve sans le savoir on
écoute le DAB parfois sans le savoir
donc il faut que cette action de
promotion du DAB se déploie donc il
existe maintenant une association pour
le rayonnement du DAB comme il y avait
eu une association pour la promotion de
la TNT en son temps il faut qu'elle
monte en puissance il faut s'adresser
aux Français il faut faire de la
pédagogie sur sur le DAB
il faut généraliser l'équipement et donc
ça je pense ça peut croiser le chemin du
Parlement lequel géant donc vous savez
que tous les véhicules qui entrent en
circulation aujourd'hui sont
automatiquement équipés de la puce
correspondante
donc là le renouvellement du parc
automobile qui est un point important
pour la radio puisque l'écoute en
mobilité est très importante va
s'accélérer 90% des voitures neuves donc
immatriculées en 2021 proposé un
récepteur date plus en série mais il
faut aussi que les récepteurs
individuels à domicile soit équipée de
cette puce et je pense que l'obligation
pourrait être posée maintenant pour les
matériels d'entrée de gamme
les récepteurs rentrés de garde qui
permettent d'accélérer à la radio
d'avoir l'obligation de disposer de
cette de cette technologie
il faut aussi prendre en compte les
contraintes économiques les acteurs
alors il y a une réforme qui est en
cours s'agissant notamment des radios
associatives et du Fonds de soutien à
l'expression radiophonique avec un
mécanisme de bonus qui est mis en place
par le ministre de la Culture on avait
beaucoup insisté sur ce point vous
rappelez monsieur le Président y compris
devant vous vos commissions à plusieurs
reprises pour plaider sur cet
accompagnement là il y a un autre point
je vous ai écrit également sur ce sujet
récemment qui mérite je crois une vraie
attention c'est celui des mentions
légales d'un sujet récurrent
c'est un poêle à gratter du secteur pour
lequel il faut aujourd'hui trouver une
réponse les mentions légales participent
d'une très bonne intention bien
évidemment de transparence et d'intérêt
de d'intérêt des Françaises et des
Français mais on peut certainement
trouver des méthodes maintenant dans la
mesure où toutes les radios se
prolongent par une activité numérique et
des sites internet faire en sorte que
les mentions légales s'expriment d'une
autre façon sans venir altérer les
messages publicitaires à un moment où le
budget publicitaire se contraint
quatrième point qui me paraît central
pendant je l'ai dit il y a plusieurs
reprises il faut moderniser je sais que
ce point ne fait pas toujours consensus
mais il faut moderniser la mesure de
l'audience en matière de radio si on
veut regarder les problèmes en face et
trouver les bonnes solutions il faut
nommer les problèmes il faut dire les
choses et donc il faut absolument
s'engager dans une modernisation
Médiamétrie y est disposée il travaille
c'est l'intérêt du secteur en tout cas
nous y sommes pour notre part tout à
fait favorable pour bien mesurer des
usages nouveaux en ce podcast ou des
technologies nouvelles je pense au dab
plus
une suggestion mais je la mets au débat
c'est une une contribution que l'art
comme en tout cas est prête à porter si
cela fait consensus parmi les acteurs si
à l'issue de cette table ronde ce point
par-intéressant
l'arcome pourrait conduire ce qui s'est
fait en Grande-Bretagne il y a deux ans
maintenant
en 2021 un exercice de livre blanc sur
le média de la radio c'est Royaume-Uni a
mené à bien cet exercice
pour regarder l'ensemble de la
problématique de ce média et à ce moment
un peu charnière à ce moment de bascule
ou la question que vous avez mis au
centre de cette table ronde de savoir à
quel moment
devra se faire la bascule entre
l'AFM c'est exercice qui prolongerait la
table ronde d'aujourd'hui d'une certaine
façon qui permettrait d'entendre
l'ensemble des points de vue aussi et
d'essayer de construire ensemble les
orientations pour l'avenir c'est une
piste que je mets sur la table en tout
cas pour dire que l'arcom est plus que
disponible sur ce dossier et décider
vraiment à ce que on puisse avancer
ensemble
notre sentiment c'est qu'il est
probablement un peu tôt aujourd'hui
compte tenu de l'usage pour fixer une
date comme on l'avait fait entre
l'analogique et le numérique en son
temps pour pour la télévision
mais il est probablement temps de
commencer à construire l'avenir de ce
média de ce point de vue là aussi de
commencer à dessiner un horizon
c'est aussi un enjeu économique parce
que bien évidemment la bascule sera
l'occasion d'alléger des coûts de
diffusion pour ces pour ces acteurs
services publics comme acteur privé donc
je pense que la probablement un petit
peu tôt pour pour fixer une date mais je
crois qu'il faut quand même engager
cette réflexion et je salue vraiment
votre initiative pionnière si je puis
dire de poser aujourd'hui cette cette
question
donc voilà je
j'ouvre ce point en conclusion de mon
propos excusant d'avoir été peut-être un
tout petit peu long en disant que nous
serions disponibles en tout cas pour
mener cet exercice à l'instar de nos
voisins grands bretons
sur cette idée de livre blanc sur sur la
radio merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur maintenant vous donner la
parole à chacun pour quelques minutes
sachant que nous avons aussi des
questions
merci monsieur le Président est-ce que
le son est le bon voilà donc je vais
démarrer merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je vais essayer de ne pas
répéter ce qu'a dit le président
roccolivier Mestre de LARCOM étant en
tout point d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit je vais pas allonger le
propos par des choses qui ont déjà été
dites donc je vais essayer de me
concentrer sur quelques réflexions que
m'inspire cette initiative dont je salue
également le caractère pionnier
vraiment je vous remercie d'avoir
l'initiative de cette table ronde parce
que ce sur quoi on discute ce matin pour
moi c'est vraiment de l'avenir de la
radio et de sa place dans les usages
audio de demain je pense que c'est
vraiment ça l'enjeu de fond qui que l'on
discute ce matin
la radio ça fait très bien rappelé par
le président de la com à une valeur très
importante pour nos concitoyens c'est
une valeur individuelle et collective
privée et public contenu du fait que
c'est 40 millions de Français qui
l'écoutent tous les jours c'est 93% des
Français qui l'écoutent chaque mois
c'est un média qui sert aussi en cas de
crise c'est un des plus résilients qui
permet une communication sur l'ensemble
du territoire donc c'est un média qui un
rôle absolument majeur et donc nous
devons nous préoccuper de la manière
dont il sera écouté dans les prochaines
années
ce qu'on voit quand on regarde
l'évolution des usages c'est que
contrairement à d'autres à un autre
média audiovisuel le poids de l'écoute
en direct reste très important
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 90% de
l'écoute
et on voit aussi que cette écoute se
fait à 80 % sur un support de diffusion
hertzienne donc avec l'AFM ça veut dire
que ce poids de l'écoute en direct est
majeur et on sait qu'il va rester très
élevé dans les prochaines années l'étude
du gouvernement britannique à laquelle
faisait référence le président de la
recommande ce projette à 15 ans et
évalue plusieurs scénarios au sein
desquels les coûts en direct va rester
majoritaire parce que la radio est un
média d'accompagnement et plus largement
l'audio est un média d'accompagnement
donc on branche sans s'arrêter pour
savoir quel programme choisir trop
longuement comme on fait pour la
télévision
c'est voilà c'est prélapse sont
importants parce que ce qui est ça veut
dire que ça diffusion la diffusion du
direct est un enjeu qui est absolument
essentiel pour le secteur or ce qui
était très bien dit c'est que le réseau
de l'AFM est saturé il est aussi
fragmenté et enfin il ne répond plus aux
usages d'aujourd'hui je vais assister un
peu sur ce point là on sait que dans les
usages audio aujourd'hui on a des
plateformes qui diffusent de la musique
qui permettent de présenter la pochette
de l'album des données sur la musique
qu'on écoute sur le programme qu'on
écoute aujourd'hui le réseau est fait et
sa diffusion est très décalée par
rapport à ces nouveaux standards
d'écoute qui sont ceux de l'audio ce qui
veut dire que si on se projette dans la
durée comment est-ce que la radio vous
va rester concurrentielle face à des
usages audio qui eux ont une modernité
dans leur code leur standard qui vont
être notre première concurrence dans les
années qui viennent
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
pense que s'interroger sur la
modernisation de cette diffusion c'est
absolument essentiel et je remercie
beaucoup l'arcom d'avoir pris
courageusement à bras le corps ce sujet
en menant une réflexion sur le
déploiement du DAB et plus d'avoir réni
l'ensemble des acteurs et nous avons
évidemment été très partant pour
accompagner avec les acteurs privés de
la radio
l'adoption de cette nouvelle technologie
nous sommes réunis au sein de multiplex
nous avons également créé ensemble une
association de promotion du DAB+ donc
c'est quelque chose voilà qui
aujourd'hui est porté par les différents
acteurs publics et privés je pense que
c'est important d'avoir aussi cette
cette unité parce que ça a des avantages
qui sont très importants je vais les
résumer très rapidement ça a des
avantages pour les éditeurs radio que
nous sommes ça répond à la problématique
de saturation de la bande passante il
peut y avoir
plus de radio il peut y avoir aussi une
diffusion meilleure sur l'ensemble du
territoire ça aussi des avantages
indéniables pour les auditeurs ils ont
été très bien rappelés par le président
de larkom sur l'absence de changement de
fréquence sur le fait que ça reste
gratuit sur aussi le fait que sur toutes
les données associées au programme sont
beaucoup plus visibles et encore
beaucoup de progrès d'ailleurs qui sont
permis par cette technologie là donc il
y a vraiment une amélioration de
l'attractivité du média radio et c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle les autres
pays européens ont adopté bien avant
nous cette technologie quand on regarde
la couverture du réseau dab plus dans
les autres pays autour de nous en Europe
beaucoup sont proches de 100%
le Danemark 99,9% la Norvège 99,7%. la
Suisse
99,5%. l'Allemagne la Grande-Bretagne la
Belgique l'Italie c'est pas que le nord
de l'Europe c'est sa descend aussi plus
vers la Méditerranée nous en France
voilà nous avons un retard qui a
commencé à être attrapé c'est bien c'est
important mais il faut aller plus loin
et ça passe évidemment par le fait de le
faire connaître aux français puisque
même si la couverture du réseau en train
de se déployer progressivement
nous avons encore que 14% des fois les
Français qui sont équipés ce qui veut
dire que il y a vraiment un enjeu
d'adoption de cette nouvelle technologie
et de savoir ce que le secteur veut
faire pour qu'elle s'adapte pour qu'elle
soit réellement adoptée
pourquoi est-ce que c'est un enjeu
important parce que aucun des acteurs du
secteur en tout cas le service public ne
pourra pas dans la durée supporter un
double coup de diffusion à un moment où
on sait qu'on a tous un média qui subit
de plein fouet une transformation
numérique qui elle-même et nécessite une
vraie transformation des redéploiements
de moyens
supporter une toux un double coup de
diffusion dans la durée je pense que
pour l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
c'est quelque chose qui sera
difficilement tenable durablement ce qui
pose la question d'une vraie stratégie
de diffusion
je pense que
l'idée que le président de LARCOM vient
de présenter de travailler sur un livre
blanc c'est à dire un travail qui permet
d'analyser l'évolution des usages
d'analyser aussi comment l'ensemble du
secteur
s'approprie va évoluer dans ce nouveau
contexte technologique qui permet
d'aboutir à une stratégie qui soit une
stratégie
concertée et je l'espère aussi
consensuel je pense que c'est très
important parce que nous devons nous
interroger sur les conditions de
transition entre l'AFM et le DAB+ ne
serait-ce que pour des raisons
économiques c'est un mode de diffusion
qui est moins coûteux vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président qui est
aussi moi coûteux énergétiquement je
pense que cette problématique là devient
de plus en plus importante aujourd'hui
avec tous les enjeux de développement
durable c'est une stratégie aussi et ça
je pense beaucoup
aux concitoyens c'est une technologie
qui est gratuite or notre enjeu à tous
c'est quand même de maintenir un média
radio dont l'accès soit libre gratuit et
qui soit facilement accessible je pense
que c'est essentiel tout à l'heure je
parlais de la valeur publique de la
radio
bon je vais donner un exemple à l'été
2020 il y a eu la tempête Alex qui a
fait que dans les Alpes du Sud il y
avait plus d'électricité il y avait plus
aucune réception les télévisions de
marché plus le seul média qui contient
de fonctionner c'était la radio qui a
permis aux services
de la préfecture de continuer à
communiquer avec les populations et leur
dire quelle mesure adopter dans ces
circonstances donc c'est un média dont
la gratuité la facilité d'accès sont
absolument essentielles alors la
question qui se pose et qui qui est au
centre aussi de nos réflexions c'est oui
mais pourquoi ne pas basculer vers un
mode de réception qui serait tout
numérique au sens de l'IP c'est à dire
reçu en wifi ou en 4G plutôt que ces
technologies là qu'il disait AB+
justement pour la raison que j'ai un
invoqué je pense qu'il faut qu'on garde
un média en France qui est un mode de
diffusion qui soit très résilient qui
soit gratuit qui repose sur une
technologie de diffusion qui soit
maîtrisée par ses acteurs donc qui soit
souveraine je pense que c'est un
véritable enjeu je pense que c'est aussi
un enjeu parce que la manière dont
l'univers numérique se déploie on voit
bien qu'il y a plein de chemins qui sont
possibles qu'on est qu'au début d'une
histoire et moi ce que je constate c'est
que dans ces univers connectés je pense
à vous en train de connecter je pense au
tableau de bord qu'est-ce qu'on voit on
voit que nous sommes face à des acteurs
qui sont dans une position de guette
keeper qui peuvent mettre en place des
stratégies de d'auto préférence qui
pourront peut-être un jour nous demander
de payer pour être diffusé sur une
enceinte connectée sur dans une voiture
donc ça va poser beaucoup de questions
pour aussi la souveraineté et la matrice
de notre propre média et je pense que ça
c'est un enjeu qui est déterminant et
quand on se projette dans l'avenir de
notre média je pense que c'est ces
questions là qui sont centrales
voilà très rapidement ce que je voulais
dire pour voilà compléter ce qui vient
d'être très bien dit par le présent de
l'arcom merci
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs Mesdames et Messieurs les élus
alors je vais très rapidement vous
rappeler ce qu'est le bureau de la radio
c'est une association qui représente les
intérêts des quatre groupes de radio
privé M6 avec RTL RTL2 et fun énergie
avec énergie Chérie FM nostalgie Rire et
Chansons Altice media avec RFM et BFM
Business et enfin Lagardère avec Europe
1 RFM et Virgin les radios du brdr
représentent près d'un auditeur sur deux
en France et les trois quarts du marché
publicitaire privé elles emploi
aujourd'hui partout en France plusieurs
milliers de salariés que ce soit des
animateurs des journalistes des
techniciens des commerciaux et enfin des
centaines d'implantations locales
partout en France
les radios produits aussi contribuent au
financement de la création à hauteur de
plus de 60 millions environ chaque année
avec la spray et la SACEM comme l'on dit
mais prédécesseurs alors plus on
n'arrive pas plus on va je vais essayer
de ne pas paraphraser mais c'est vrai
que le DAB+ on en est convaincu nous les
radios privés c'est un très important
pour la modernisation de la radio nous y
sommes tous engagés
cependant c'est vrai et comme recolivier
l'a dit cela tombe à un moment compliqué
pour le marché publicitaire et donc pour
nous radio privé pour nous pour nos
financements mais nous ne sommes pas
dogmatiques nous sommes ouverts à la
discussion nous sommes ouverts au débat
car comme vous l'avez tous les deux
c'est essentiel pour l'évolution de ce
média qui est tellement important pour
les Français mais ce que ce que nous
pensons nous les radios privés c'est
qu'il est un petit peu tôt pour un
calendrier pour l'arrêt réel de enfin en
tout cas pour la rétrogressive de l'AFM
tant qu'il n'aura pas été répondu de
manière précise pour nous à quatre
conditions qui nous semblent
obligatoires vraiment obligatoire la
première c'est de dupliquer la
couverture FM y compris le local sur le
réseau DAB+ c'est vrai qu'au début
l'arcom vous nous aviez présenté un
instrument de modernisation de
complémentarité et que si l'on va vers
une substitution il ne faut en aucun cas
c'est très important pour nous renoncer
à l'implantation de nos de nos
programmes locaux
deuxième condition la stabilisation
d'offre d'opérateurs disponibles
aujourd'hui on a parlé beaucoup de
financement donc c'est vrai que par
exemple à Paris il y a aujourd'hui sans
radio donc quand il y a 100 radios il y
a une dissolution des sources de
financement donc ce que nous préconisons
c'est d'accorder les fréquences
disponibles en priorité aux opérateurs
existants troisième condition
obligatoire pour nous pour évoluer vers
la duab plus vous l'avez dit aussi mais
c'est de s'assurer que tous les Français
évidemment est un récepteur dab plus
pour le capter c'est-à-dire
d'interdire la vente de récepteurs radio
qui n'est pas le DAB+ parce que c'est
évidemment il faut que tous les Français
tu as parlé civils de liberté mais
peut-être avant la liberté il y a
l'accessibilité qui est essentielle
et enfin quatrième condition qui nous
semble obligatoire c'est évidemment quel
est l'engagement réel de l'état à nos
côtés quand je parle d'engagement je
parle d'accompagnement aussi aujourd'hui
à terme le DAB+ pour les radios privés
quand je dis à terme c'est dans les 5 6
ans ça va nous coûter plus d'un million
par radio donc évidemment c'est un
budget qui est très important pour nous
avec la double diffusion ça nous fait
des doubles frais à l'heure où comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure le financement
de nos radios est essentiellement fait
par la publicité dans un marché qui
souffre donc il est très clair que nous
avons besoin pour aller un peu plus loin
sur le diabi+ d'une aide très précise de
l'état tu as parlé on a aussi des
mesures qui ne sont pas seulement
financières vocaliers tu as parlé des
mentions légales qui sont un vrai frein
pour les radios privés mais nous avons
aussi les quotas nous avons aussi une
série de de
discussion en tout cas de combat où nous
avons réellement besoin d'être
accompagné par les public pour pour
avancer voilà j'ai été courte mais
Claire voilà j'espère
Christophe
monsieur le Président bonjour Merci pour
cette initiative je vais tout aussi
clair que mes prédécesseurs je l'espère
et aussi court que constant ces premiers
je représente le circuit et le syndicat
effectivement des radios indépendantes
françaises des radios qui souvent ont
été créés au début des années 80 elles
sont 170 aujourd'hui être fédérés au
sein de notre structure et il se trouve
qu'à l'heure actuelle nous faisons le
tour de France de nos adhérents Lyon
hier Bordeaux la semaine dernière et la
question du début nous est posée
toujours c'est une préoccupation réelle
pour les acteurs que nous représentons
mais j'y reviendrai nous touchons au
travers de ces 170 questions 7 millions
de diteurs tous les jours je ne vais pas
redire ça a été dit à quel point la
radio est importante la période de crise
sanitaire que nous avons traversé
approuvé plus que jamais quel rôle nous
remplissons depuis la création de
stations il y a 40 ans pour sourire un
peu nos radios étaient peut-être un peu
considérés sur les territoires qu'elle
couvre comme comme les médias de papa
mais il se trouve que le le fabriqué au
bout de la rue est redevenu très
tendance et nous sourions parce qu'on a
toujours été fabriqué au bout de la rue
et aujourd'hui est considérer comme
étant vertueux c'est vrai et ça l'est
depuis la création de nos stations nos
170 adhérents emploi 2500 personnes en
France dont 500 journalistes nous
regroupons des radios thématiques
musicales parfois avec des diffusions
larges parfois nationales ou quasiment
en tout cas les y prétendent nous
regroupons des radiologues des radios
régionales et également des pures
payeurs du dab+, certains acteurs ont
choisi de se concentrer exclusivement
sur ce mode de diffusion ils ont fait ce
pari là nous les accompagnons ils ont
d'autres préoccupations évidemment mais
notre rôle c'est de c'est de soutenir
l'ensemble de la filière je suis
moi-même moi-même acteur de la radio en
Alsace j'ai eu le plaisir tout à l'heure
de saluer Claude Kern qui qui c'est une
nature du Bas-Rhin et saluait les
achèques qui portent un presque un joli
nom qui quasiment orthographié comme le
mien
de petites de petites choses en
préambule je voudrais rappeler que il y
a presque dix ans maintenant les
premiers les premières zones à être
couvertes par le DB+ c'était Paris
Marseille et Nice et nous adhérons du
serti et été parmi les premiers acteurs
à prendre part à cette initiative qui
était à l'époque un peu hasardeuse ça
fait donc neuf ans que sur nos comptes
d'exploitation apparaissent chaque année
des coûts évidemment de diffusion je ne
l'ai pas dit tout à l'heure mais tous
nos adhérents vivent exclusivement et à
100% de la publicité qu'il commercialise
et l'exploitation de leur support audio
et digitaux et donc ça cette double
diffusion à un vrai coup de pin-novant
certains nous adhérents commencent à ne
plus y croire il y a baisser les bras il
est donc pour anticiper la réponse à la
question que vous posez tout à l'heure
oui apportons dès à présent de les
accompagner et de fixer un cap mais j'y
reviendrai ça aussi donc neuf ans de de
parti pris pour nous en matière de
défense de DAB+ pour une raison
principale et Sybille le rappeler tout à
l'heure la souveraineté de notre
diffusion et stratégique on l'a vu
récemment avec des bras de fer entre
entre des opérateurs de télévision nous
ne voulons pas vivre ça la FM nous a
permis d'être souvent en matière de
diffusion la création récente d'un d'une
belle expérience qui s'appelle Radio
Player va également en ce sens nous ne
dépendons de personnes nous sommes chez
nous avec l'ensemble des acteurs de la
région on ne l'a pas de la de la
profession de l'a pas dit encore donc le
DAB+ nous permet aussi de rester maître
de notre diffusion c'est effectivement
essentiel et nous voulons nous ne
voulons pas dépendre des fournisseurs
d'accès Internet qui souvent sont logés
ailleurs qu'en France vous le savez bien
un autre élément que je voudrais
soumettre et qui
nous taquine depuis quelques mois
quelques semaines plus particulièrement
on assiste un radio bashing régulier à
l'heure actuelle à chaque fois que les
audiences sont proclamés on nous dit oui
la radio perd de son de son terrain
c'est vrai les crises sanitaires ont
engendré des des modifications quant à
la consommation médias on le voit bien
pour autant et on le rappelait tout à
l'heure 40 millions de personnes nous
écoutent régulièrement 93% des commencer
à l'échelle d'un mois écoute la radio
donc voyons le verre à moitié plein
parce qu'il est la radio reste puissante
à nous de faire ce qu'il faut en termes
de programmes et de mode de diffusion
pour qu'elle le reste demain et en tout
cas nous on est on est convaincu du fait
que pendant quelques années encore 5 10
15 30 ans 50 ans certainement la radio
continuera à fonctionner si on est
capable de prendre les virages face au
canon nous trouverons maintenant je
voudrais pour être positif rappeler
quand même que collectivement nous avons
réussi depuis 10 ans le CSA de l'époque
que nous incitait à faire l'expérience
de DAB+ nous l'avons fait
les acteurs et c'est le deuxième point
de satisfaction nationaux nous ont
rejoint dans cette aventure public et
privée et puis nous avons ça a été
rappelé également réussi à créer cette
association de promotion pour le DAB+
ensemble pour le DAB+ maintenant pour
que nous ayons les moyens effectivement
de nous adresser au grand public et à la
population au sens large pour que
effectivement on intègre ce mode de
réception dans ces dans ces habitudes de
consommation de la radio au quotidien
je termine par deux points d'extinction
de la FM évidemment se posera un jour
aujourd'hui bien entendu le déploiement
du Deb est plus n'est pas mature pour
autant on l'a rappelé la diffusion des
plus c'est particulièrement vertueuse en
matière de consommation d'énergie et
c'est double coup de diffusion si nous
pouvons effectivement
nous en passer dans dans 10 ou 15 ans on
nous applaudirons dès demain donc je ne
voudrais pas que vous soyons considérés
comme étant réfractaire à l'arrêt de
l'AFM c'est simplement une question de
calendrier il faut que que nous en
parlions bien entendu et oui je le redis
et je m'arrête après cela
l'accompagnement de nos adhérents
acteurs dans le domaine du Diabet plus
depuis bientôt 10 ans je le disais et
maintenant nécessaire avec un cap que
nous que nous partagerons avec
l'ensemble des acteurs
merci Monsieur Charles monsieur Boutrin
bonjour monsieur le Président je tenais
également à vous remercier de cette de
cette commission je remercie également
mon délégué général Christophe bed BD
qui est présent dans la salle et qui
pourra répondre
à certaines questions le cas échéant
nous je remercie évidemment les
sénatrices et les sénateurs présents
nombreux et je sais que votre
institution monsieur le Président
au travers
de vos collègues a toujours été très
attentifs aux radios locales et
notamment aux radios locales associatifs
associatif depuis
1981 parce que nous sommes comme vous
sur les territoires
les radios associatifs se sont 700 très
petites entreprises de 1 à un salarié
jusqu'à 8 10 salariés très implantés
donc sur les territoires avec comme la
rappeler madame la Présidente tout à
l'heure nous sommes et monsieur le
Président de la Rome
nous sommes en effet très résilient et
très efficace notamment en cas de crise
d'où l'intérêt d'ailleurs de la
poursuite de la diffusion
par voie herdienne qu'elle soit en FM ou
qu'elle soit aujourd'hui en date plus
donc ce sont 700 opérateurs de 1400
salariés très résilient et très actif
sur les territoires un million quatre
auditrices et auditeurs fidèles et nous
avons depuis longtemps abordé le virage
du numérique on a commencé nos premières
expérimentations certains d'entre vous
s'en souviennent ici sur un autre siège
social à l'époque
qui était la tour Philippe la tour
Pleyel finalement la tour Philippe qui
est actuellement à rénovation au cœur du
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis avec
le soutien de la dodgeval et de
l'Université de Shanghai et c'était une
aventure extraordinaire nous avons
commencé à expérimenter certaines normes
de diffusion
d'abord le DRM et puis ensuite nous
avons bifurqué très vite sur le DA plus
et nous avons lancé à Nantes le premier
avec le soutien du Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel à l'époque le premier
multiplex qui comprenait d'ailleurs
un service du service public sur la
région nantaise qui émet d'ailleurs
depuis 2010 et qui était
régularisé et réguler depuis au fur et à
mesure de notre histoire
nous avons donc toujours milité nous
avons toujours été convaincus que ce
soit au plan national ou sur les
territoires de la nécessité de la
modernisation de la diffusion tout
simplement pour une question comme mes
collègues l'ont parfaitement rappelé
accroissement maintien et accroissement
de la diversité des éditeurs des radios
accroissement de potentiel d'auditrice
et d'auditeurs et également on l'a
souligné tout à l'heure un confort
d'écoute incomparable y compris par là
par rapport à la FM pour faire simple on
passe de des grandes ondes ou des
moyennes ondes à l'AFM est bien
aujourd'hui on passe de la FM aux dames
en matière de qualité d'écoute et comme
le disait le président reconnu les
Mestre quand on a commencé à écouter sur
le DAB dans notre cuisine ou en radio on
s'en passe plus l'intérêt du DAB c'est
en effet vous l'avez rappelé j'y
reviendrai pas c'est l'accessibilité
universelle et la gratuité c'est ça en
effet qu'il aujourd'hui à préserver bien
évidemment il y a d'autres modèles
il y a d'autres modèles et on sait que
certains poussent notamment les Gafa et
leur filiales vers le tout IP
c'est donc pour nous
pour tout le monde un défi industriel
qu'il faut sur lesquels il faut il faut
se pencher et qu'il faut réussir quel
que soit
les chemins qui seront suivis vers l'IP
vers le DAB vers la diffusion par
voyardienne il y a peut-être d'autres
voix également donc de toute façon il
faut réussir le passage du DAB même si
nous sommes et on le sait on le voit au
travers des expérimentations qui ont été
menées notamment depuis 2004 2005-2007
en ce qui nous concerne même si nous
sommes un petit peu en retard
c'est-à-dire que nous n'avons pas le
choix de réussir le défi du passage
partielle ou total on va le voir tout à
l'heure au date plus d'abord parce que
c'est un défi
sur la diversité des éditeurs sur la
qualité d'écoute pour les auditeurs et
les auditrices les éditeurs j'ai dit en
premier et puis ensuite parce que c'est
un défi industriel nous avons un défi de
l'équipement des ménages et de
l'équipement évidemment mobilité je
parle des véhicules ici qui est
considérable avec en effet là des marges
de manœuvre des de la valeur ajoutée qui
pour notre pays et pour nos
fabricants en tout cas les fabricants
européens et les distributeurs au sens
parce que sur la question des
distributeurs au sens des marchands on
va dire de postes qui sont ce qui est
considérables ce défi est considérable
c'est un marché de plusieurs milliards
d'euros il faut arriver à remplir ce
défi pour ce pour réussir ce défi comme
mes collègues l'ont expliqué il faut
accompagner les éditeurs quels qu'ils
soient les éditeurs nationaux les
éditeurs privés
simplifier leur démarche les soutenir
financièrement et également je j'y
reviendrai les éditeurs territoriaux que
nous sommes les radios sur les
territoires que nous sommes mais là je
sais Monsieur le Président vous distrait
comme tout le monde ici d'ailleurs
particulièrement attentif puisque notre
modèle économique passe en partie en
partie pas seulement il faut aussi tuer
certaines ardeurs et certains
stéréotypes en partie par la subvention
mais c'est bien la loi de 86 a instauré
un système d'aide publique pour les
radios locales de type associatif
avec la bienvenue qui a rassemblé
l'ensemble de l'arc politique à cette
époque sous avec la bienveillante
attention de Philippe Léotard c'est
l'article 29 de la lot 86 qui instaure
donc une aide et un soutien public aux
partiel aux radios associatifs qui
remplissent un cahier des charges
relativement exigeant et on va encore
tuer une idée reçue
très contrôlé très contrôlé d'une
manière ou d'une autre donc nous
remplissons ce cahier des charges nous
voulons remplir et réussir ce défi avec
l'ensemble des opérateurs nous nous
disons historiquement je vous
l'expliquais depuis très longtemps nous
y croyons ministre croyons pourquoi nous
y croyons parce que c'est l'intérêt du
pays c'est un c'est l'intérêt d'une
c'est comme je l'ai dit un véritable
défi industriel il faut arrêter en effet
de vendre par dans les magasins y
compris d'ailleurs dans certaines de nos
grandes chaînes il faut arrêter de
vendre de la camelote chinoise ou en
effet vous avez des postes d'ABS qui
commencent à 19 ou 29 euros et qui ne
sont j'allais dire monsieur le Président
qui dégoûte l'auditeur du DAB il faut
donc réguler cette distribution adopter
des normes de qualité sur les récepteurs
et
partout de faire baisser par la
massification de faire baisser le prix
des récepteurs pour que l'ensemble des
ménages puissent puisse s'équiper
notamment à la maison sur les véhicules
on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui depuis le
premier depuis l'obligation du 1er
janvier 2021 on va dire qu'entre 2
millions et 3 millions de véhicules sont
primo équipés c'est donc une bonne
nouvelle monsieur le Président une bonne
nouvelle du point de vue du défi
industriel que nous devons réussir
ensemble l'ensemble de la nation doit
réussir ce défi industriel pour des
raisons strictement économiques et
ce taux d'équipement des véhicules
avance il avance doucement il avance
avec le renouvellement du parc
automobile c'est donc une un bon signe
nous ne pouvons donc plus reculer au
regard du défi industriel que nous
devons relever aujourd'hui c'est amorcé
la politique des arcs et des nœuds a
permis un peu tardivement mais a permis
à ce que les grands opérateurs
rejoignent les éditeurs territoriaux
locaux que ce soit les radios locales
commerciales ou les nôtres les radios
locales associatives c'est une
excellente chose maintenant il faut
comme vous l'avez posé monsieur le
Président il faut réussir le soutien de
la puissance publique pour cela faut-il
suivre la voie qui a été suivie au
moment de la télévision numérique
terrestre avec le président Chirac qui
avait mis quand même de l'argent sur la
table avec la représentation nationale
bien sûr je n'en sais rien mais je pense
qu'il faut ouvrir ce débat sur le
soutien massif de la puissance publique
à ce stade de notre défi industriel qui
est plus ça c'est la première question
donc la promotion oui
la question de la planification j'ai
presque terminé la question de la
planification elle existe la
planification
il y a pas besoin d'en faire plus
certains pensent qu'il faut l'accélérer
et ce que l'arcome a les moyens
d'accélérer la planification la feuille
du roter là il faut maintenant la
respecter en revanche monsieur le
Président l'art comme a une difficulté
et cela nous concerne nous acteurs des
territoires sénatrice et sénateur comme
nous radiologue c'est la territorialité
de la planification il n'est pas sûr que
l'ensemble des zones blanches en termes
de date plus soit aujourd'hui
efficacement planifié
c'est pour ça que nous allons je suggère
ici une idée qui pourrait être ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la solution
distributeur la solution distributeur
c'est tout simplement le fait que la com
lance un appel à candidature sur les
zones rurales de notamment en montagne
mais également les bassins de vie
d'emploi et d'écoute inférieur à 50 000
habitants qui ne sont pas ou peu
couverts aujourd'hui sauf évidemment
dans le pourtour du système des arcs et
des nœuds c'est-à-dire des grandes
métropoles et où il y a un déficit de
radio autorisé en dab et un déficit
manifestement d'appels à candidature on
a du mal il est aujourd'hui un système
qui est prévu par l'article 28-4 de la
loi de 1986 qui est ce qu'on appelle la
solution distributeur et c'est là comme
qui a la main là-dessus c'est à dire que
en effet on peut
confié un distributeur qui peut être un
opérateur de multiplex le soin de
planifier une zone territoriale et
notamment les zones je pense là aux
zones territoriales
de type
semi-urbaine ou rural ou de montagne
sachant que 29 vient d'être aménagé en
ce qui concerne les zones de montagne il
y a 2 ans dans le cas de la loi montagne
de
non nous sommes là en face d'un défi et
d'une idée qui pourrait contribuer à
réaménager ou aménager ou accélérer le
déploiement du da+ sur des zones moins
denses qui sont aujourd'hui à mon avis
insuffisamment planifiés et
insuffisamment
[Musique]
occupé c'est la première idée et puis
j'en ai une deuxième parce qu'on parle
beaucoup en effet de l'implantation de
l'implémentation ou de la possibilité
puisque c'est déjà implémenté des puces
favorisant la réception herdienne
qu'elle soit FM ou qu'elle soit dame
dans les smartphones bah c'est un peu
compliqué parce que on a loupé le virage
il y a une dizaine d'années le Mexique a
réussi mais nous on ne sait pas penché
puis il y avait certainement d'autres
intérêts des intérêts différents que
d'autres pays et finalement on n'a pas
réussi à imposer l'activation
euh de ces puces de chez gipset dans les
smartphones donc finalement c'est vrai
les gens écoutent la radio au travers
des smartphones et sur de l'IP puisque
toute façon c'est possible à peu près
partout ici il y a en effet également
l'un des défis
d'abord il faut s'opposer à certaines
idées qui diraient que d'abord on arrête
tout l'a fait mais puis toute façon tout
sera IP et on va même arrêter
l'implémentation de puces dans les
smartphones il faut ça c'est des idées
qui sont poussées notamment par le Gafa
il faut arrêter cette histoire parce
qu'il faut maintenir cette opportunité
aux opérateurs de faire ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire et on laisse et à ce
niveau là le marché
travaillait comme il se doit en fonction
des appétences et des intérêts de chacun
en revanche
aujourd'hui apparaît depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs la 5G broadcast dont la
responsable sur la bande du HF dont la
responsabilité n'est ne relève pas de la
recette mais relève de l'arcome et là
monsieur le Président je me permets de
signaler qu'il y a un gisement de
diffusion broadcast pour l'ensemble des
opérateurs pas seulement les opérateurs
territoriaux mais ça pourrait nous aider
aussi nous en tant qu'opérateur
territoriale sur le
l'activation ou une étude concernant la
5G broadcast sur les smartphones j'en ai
terminé je répondrai volontiers à
l'ensemble de vos questions sur ce défi
industriel mais jeunes président merci
alors il y a pas mal de questions du
reste je vais commencer par celle de
notre rapporteur pour avis des crédits
budgétaires Jean Raymond Hugonnet merci
Président si vous le permettez à ce
moment-là pour plus de dynamisme et
peut-être d'efficacité que chaque
interlocuteur réponde à la question
puisque bien sûr merci vous ne m'en
voudrez pas monsieur le Président de la
Recon si ma première question s'adresse
à Madame Sybille présidente de Radio
France en tant qu' ancien membre du
conseil d'administration je m'en sens un
petit peu obligé
madame la Présidente voilà plusieurs
années que je vous entends sur le DAB+
vous en faites un axe majeur de votre
stratégie avec vos équipes comment Radio
France pourrait-elle jouer un rôle de
pionnier dans cette transition vers le
DAB plus est-ce que Radio France
pourrait en particulier envisager de
cesser la diffusion de certaines de ces
antennes en FM pour privilégier une
transition vers le DAB+ avec pour
objectif bien sûr un accompagnement pour
ne pas perdre d'auditeurs
merci Monsieur sénateur de cette
question qui va me permettre de revenir
sur certains points qui ont été évoqués
je pense que on voit tout ce matin qui a
consensus entre les différents acteurs
sur l'intérêt de cette nouvelle
technologie donc le saut technologique
qui est accomplir et que toute la
question en fait qui nous préoccupe tous
c'est la question de la transition quel
modalité c'est à dire qui en supporte le
coup et on sait que plus cette
transition est longue plus on a un
double coup de diffusion à supporter
plus c'est coûteux et aucun acteur ne
souhaite ce surcoût en tout cas nous
services publics on sait qu'on ne pourra
pas le le porter huguard au moyen de
nous disposons durablement donc il y a
plus la transition et longue plus le
double coup sera difficile à supporter
mais cette transition pour qu'elle soit
réussie il y a des conditions et je
rejoins tout à fait celle que Constance
baquet a énoncé au nom du bureau de la
c'est il faut que la couverture
soit étendue c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on est en dessous de 50%, faut qu'on
arrive au moins à 75% qui la cible fixée
par la stratégie de déploiement défini
par l'arcome voir qu'on se pose la
question peut-être aussi au-delà parce
qu'en fait c'est un peu la condition qui
a été rappelée il faut qu'on retrouve
les conditions de couverture actuelle
donc ça va poser la vraiment la question
de la couverture des Français ça pose
aussi une deuxième question qui est
celle de l'équipement des Français c'est
à dire qu'il faut que les Français
soient équipés pour qu'ils puissent
recevoir cette technologie ça veut dire
que basculer d'une diffusion FM vers
exclusivement le DAB et plus ne peut se
faire qu'une fois que ces deux
conditions sont remplies sauf à
fragiliser considérablement notre média
c'est le cas pour l'ensemble des acteurs
ça sera le cas pour nous c'est le cas
pour les acteurs privés je pense que de
ce point de vue là on se rejoint tous
notre enjeu collectif c'est de faire en
sorte que les Français connaissent ces
technologies qu'on se pose la question
aussi d'accompagner les citoyens dans
l'adoption de de cette technologie qu'on
leur fasse connaître que se pose la
question du des modes de récepteur c'est
à dire quelqu'un évoqué leur qualité
c'est une vraie question il y a la
question de leur coûts tout comme au
moment de la diffusion de la TNT ce sont
des questions qui
ont été au cœur de la stratégie aussi de
déploiement de la TNT donc je pense que
c'est vraiment les enjeux et services
publics accompagnera mais il doit rester
parce que
sa nature même c'est quand même
l'accessibilité à tous les Français il
doit rester accessible à tous les
Français donc nous accompagnerons
évidemment le déploiement comme nous
l'avons fait en étant dans les
multiplexes moteurs dans la connaissance
et acteur aussi de toutes les réflexions
stratégiques pour le faire comme nous
l'avons été les dernières années en
revanche je pense que arrêtez
prématurément la diffusion à FM de
certaines de nos radio ça veut dire que
le contribuable n'aura pas les
conditions suffisantes pour avoir accès
dans les conditions actuelles donc c'est
pas pareil que pour l'ensemble des
autres acteurs c'est vraiment la
question de la transition à quel moment
sans fragiliser le média son fragilisés
aucun des acteurs de ce média nous
aurons les conditions nécessaires pour
envisager comme le font d'autres pays
puisque le gouvernement britannique a
engagé une réflexion dessus tout comme
les Allemands les Suisses les Danois les
Norvégiens tous les autres quand est-ce
que pour justement que le secteur de la
radio n'est pas un supporter un double
coup on engage une réflexion sur la
transition et le passage d'un mode de
diffusion à l'autre donc vous posez la
bonne question comment est-ce qu'on
passe un mode de diffusion à l'autre je
pense qu'il faut qu'on travaille tous
sur cette transition et ces conditions
deuxième question cette question
s'adresse cette fois-ci au président de
l'arcom vous l'avez évoqué un petit peu
tout à l'heure dans votre propos
illuminaire mais quels sont selon vous
aujourd'hui les obstacles au
développement du DAB+ en France et que
pensez-vous des débats justement qui
émergent sur l'intérêt d'organiser une
transition entre l'AFM et le DAB plus
je voudrais juste compléter ce qu'a dit
Sybille et vous donner quelques
informations sur l'Europe et sur la
façon dont les choses évoluent en Europe
on a parlé du modèle du Royaume-Uni le
DAB a été lancé en 1920 on a commencé à
travailler sur le DAB Royaume-Uni en
1995 donc il y a près de 30 ans et
aujourd'hui le calendrier arrive avec
une extinction qui devait qui devra être
a priori fête au plus tôt en 2030 donc
il y a quand même aujourd'hui chez nos
confrères européens c'est vrai que les
exemples dont vous avez parlé monsieur
le Président sur la Norvège et la Suisse
sont des pays qui sont quand même assez
différents des nôtres en revanche quand
on regarde ceux qui sont plus près des
nôtres je pense à l'Allemagne je pense à
l'Autriche ou
à la Suède ça a été lancé le DAB plus a
été lancé en national il y a plus de 10
ans mais aujourd'hui il y a encore une
une double diffusion donc c'est pas
aussi simple à mettre en place que cela
et je redis une petite chose comme j'ai
été très courte tout à l'heure c'est
vrai sur les économies dont on a parlé
sur sur l'accompagnement de l'État a
priori le jour où le financement du DAB
à terme sera fait donc il y aura des
économies considérables pour l'état de
l'ordre de 40 millions s'ils étaient
l'AFM sur le sur le service public c'est
vrai qu'avec ces 40 millions on peut
penser qu'il y aura je parlais de
financement tout à l'heure une aide de
l'État pour nous tous qui pourrait être
de l'ordre attends c'est pas moi de
donner les sommes mais quand je vous
donne quand même un ordre d'idée sur ces
40 millions donc si on pouvait en
récolter un petit peu puisque nous avons
toujours considéré et le président de
larkom le sait je lui dis à chaque fois
que nous nous voyons c'est-à-dire assez
souvent que les radios privés en termes
d'aide sont un petit peu le parent
pauvre du paysage audiovisuel français
je vous en prie madame la Présidente
vous aviez naturellement précédent c'est
bien entendu votre dernière expression
toujours douloureuse pour un magistrat
de la Cour des comptes mais c'est vrai
que le soutien de l'État est toujours
fortement sollicité dans notre beau pays
je réponds à votre à votre question bon
le premier point quand même
de constat qu'il faut faire c'est
l'adhésion de l'ensemble des acteurs du
secteur des radios associatives au
grande radio privé en passant par le
service public sur l'engagement dans la
voie du déploiement du DAB+ et je leur
ai dit dans dans un concert européen
plus plus général
et ça passe pour répondre à la question
du sénateur Hugonnet par un certain
nombre de conditions qui ont déjà qui
ont déjà été évoqué
accélérer le déploiement donc nous nous
avons une feuille de route que nous
avons réactualisé pour accélérer nos
procédures qui va à ce stade jusqu'à
2024 avec un objectif cible que la
présidente vaille a évoqué de 75 à 80 à
80 % de couverture de couverture du
territoire
en tout cas je le dis ici bien
évidemment on déploiera nos meilleurs
efforts pour
dans le cadre procédural qui s'impose à
nous pour accélérer au maximum ce
déploiement la deuxième condition je
l'ai dit c'est un effort général de
promotion du DAB+ ça je crois que cette
action il faut qu'on l'amène tous
ensemble vous le faites d'ailleurs sur
vos antennes d'ores et déjà
l'association existe il faut remercier
le ministère de la Culture qui à notre
demande si j'avais plaidé en ce sens
auprès de Madame Bachelot en son temps
l'État a apporté une contribution à ses
campagnes d'information et je souhaite
qu'elle puisse se prolonger au-delà des
efforts des différents des différents
acteurs
il faut généraliser l'équipement
sur l'équipement monsieur le Président
puisqu'on est dans une enceinte
parlementaire éminente il y a un sujet
législatif quand même devant nous qui a
été évoqué sur plusieurs points donc il
y a une obligation d'intégration de la
puce DAB+ dans l'ensemble des
équipements qui viennent aujourd'hui sur
le marché et notamment les produits
d'entrée de gamme qui ont été évoqués
par par le président Bouteron dans son
dans son intervention
il y a un deuxième sujet qui a été
évoqué par la présidente si je ne me
trompe dans son intervention sécurisé
l'équipement des voitures neuves dans la
durée en imposant un tunnel des AB+ au
véhicules et équipés d'un système de
diffusion sonore
pour éviter un risque d'éviction compte
tenu des technologies modernes qui se
déploie qui ont été évoqués ici donc ça
je crois qu'il y a un enjeu pour
l'ensemble des acteurs de la radio de
sécuriser l'équipement des véhicules
automobiles d'un poste et d'un tunnel
des habit plus c'est ça c'est une
initiative qui relève du législative et
sans vouloir insister sur ce point
puisqu'il a été évoqué par plusieurs
acteurs trouver une issue sur une
mention légale et je pense à l'instar de
l'exercice que nous menons aujourd'hui
le Parlement semble leur est le mieux
placé pour mener une mission brève
d'écoute de l'ensemble des acteurs pour
voir quelle issue on pourrait trouver à
cactus pour reprendre l'expression du
président Pompidou sur un autre sujet
qui est que sont les mentions que sont
les mentions les mentions légales
sur le sur le déploiement je veux quand
même dire un mot au président Boutrin je
l'ai bien entendu
on avait bâti une stratégie et je crois
qu'il était extrêmement pertinent de
privilégier c'est comme ça qu'on a sorti
le DAB+ de l'ornière il faut bien le
dire parce que
chaque constance Maquet en France il est
évoqué depuis très très longtemps le
président Charles qui a évoqué les
premières expérimentations mais ce
dossier a été complètement en calamine
et il faut quand même dire les choses et
la stratégie qui a été celle de
l'institution de privilégier les grands
axes routiers et les grandes
agglomérations qui permet aux grands
acteurs privés de d'avoir un modèle
économique par le bassin des coudes qui
est le leur et pertinent il a permis
d'enclencher la mécanique mais notre
feuille de route et vous le savez très
bien qui va jusqu'à 2024 privilégie
maintenant des couvertures de zones qui
ne sont pas que des grandes zones
d'agglomération
urbaines ou des grands axes routiers
mais qui privilégie
des zones beaucoup moins denses
auxquelles je le sais vous êtes attachés
et vous avez évoqué je vais pas rentrer
dans la technique ici des bassins
d'écoute plus restreints avec une
technologie
qu'on retrouve dans certains autres pays
c'est la technologie pour employer un
français d'Outre Atlantique le Smalls
quelle dab donc indépendant du DAB+ sur
de petit échelles
c'est un sujet que nous connaissons bien
et sur lequel notre maison au travail
vous le savez de même que sur la 5G
broadcast des expérimentations ont été
autorisées et il faut voir ce que la 5G
broadcast donne avant d'en tirer d'en
tirer l'ensemble des enseignements donc
voilà je pense qu'il y a un ensemble de
faisceaux et puis un objectif cible à un
moment de bascule avec les conditions
qui ont été évoquées donc une fois
encore je le redis ici nous nous sommes
tout à fait prêts à nous livrer un
exercice de livre blanc à l'instar de ce
qu'on fait nos amis britanniques qui
permettrait de bâtir des scénarios
d'ailleurs fixer peut-être des options
possibles de calendrier constance
marqués à évoqué l'échéance de 2030 je
pense qu'à partir de cette zone chez nos
amis anglais chez nos amis anglais mais
quand je regarde la feuille de route qui
est la nôtre et ce que sera le
déploiement à partir de 24 25 en tout
cas après les appels d'offres qu'on
lancera en 2024 on se rapprochera quand
même de la zone des 75 80% et donc on
pourra commencer à envisager cette
hypothèse un instant de nos amis anglais
j'espère avoir répondu à votre question
monsieur sénateur merci troisième
question et dernière peut-être pour
cette série
ma troisième question va s'adresser à
l'est si je puis dire de l'hémicycle
c'est-à-dire monsieur chalk
les radios indépendantes considèrent que
leur accès aux fréquences est fait mais
souvent insuffisante pour de nombreux
territoires le président de la comme l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure estimez-vous que
le DAB plus
susceptibles de favoriser davantage le
plus réalisme dans l'offre radio est-ce
que les radios indépendantes pourront
cependant assumer longtemps cette double
diffusion
nous adhérents se sont engagés dans
l'expérience il y a 10 ans du diabi+
avec conviction souvent mais surtout
avec intuition et par définition elles
n'ont pas toutes convergé ces intuitions
c'est à dire que certaines stations ont
choisi de couvrir le même territoire
avec un double une double diffusion du
même programme d'autres en ont profité
pour créer un programme
initié par le premier et qui permettait
d'offrir une offre de proposer une offre
alternative et d'autres ont considéré
que leur zone primaire étant desservie
par la FM ils allaient pouvoir aller
plus loin en matière de diffusion et
donc on prétendu à des fréquences plus
éloignées de leur base aux initiales on
voit bien qu'en matière de de stratégie
il faut un moment qu'on s'entende sur
les parties prix techniques et donc
aussi de contenu pour répondre à votre à
votre question aujourd'hui encore
l'arcom et on va évidemment louer ces
initiatives continuent à attribuer des
fréquences aux opérateurs indépendants
mais pas uniquement en FM on voit bien
que la FM continuait à être pendant
combien de temps c'est l'une des
questions à laquelle il faudrait que
nous répondions c'est l'objet de la
réunion de ce matin et bien entendu nous
nos acteurs on l'a dit sont nombreux 170
membres pour ce qui nous concerne avec
des envies avec avec un credo en ce
média qui les poussent parfois à vouloir
s'étendre davantage et on est forcément
souvent frustré par le fait de ne
pouvoir sortir de ses bases je je veux
pas raconter là la frustration récente
qui a été la mienne en la matière donc
oui on considère globalement qu'on n'est
pas suffisamment doté en matière de
fréquence FM bien entendu le Diabet plus
demain nous permettrait de toucher des
territoires plus larges donc ça va
évidemment dans le sens de la
satisfaction de nos de nos adhérents
bien sûr
alors je vais regrouper les questions
maintenant pour ceux qui souhaitent en
poser en commençant par Monique de Marco
ensuite Jérémy Baki David Assouline et
Sylvie Robert
oui
on l'a bien vu le DAB plus le
développement très très petit à petit et
je dois dire quand j'ai je préfère
direct quand j'ai dit que je venais à
cette table ronde je dois dire que dans
mon entourage personne ne connaissait
l'existence du DAB+ donc il y a vraiment
un gros problème de communication
donc c'est quand même un milieu ouvert
que je fréquente mais je vous le dis
donc concrètement comment allez-vous
envisager cette information cette
communication auprès du grand public
déjà le terme excusez-moi de vous dire
que dab plus ça ne parle pas
c'est vraiment une abréviation qui vient
de l'anglais
écoutez je crois qu'il faudrait
peut-être commencer par imaginer un
autre terme en communication pour
je pense qu'au préalable l'erreur ici en
France c'est ça ça ne parle pas bon je
poursuis très rapidement
comment comptez-vous donc mesurer
l'audience
qu'elle serait selon vous la meilleure
façon de mesurer cette audience cette
audience et AB + est-il d'ailleurs
nécessaire distinguer les audiences
selon les habitudes d'écoute des
auditeurs et j'ai une question pour
monsieur le Président de larkom
serait-il nécessaire que le législateur
adapte les procédures d'appel aux
candidatures pour permettre un
déploiement plus rapide du DAB+
merci monsieur le Président merci à
l'ensemble des intervenantes et des
intervenants pour pour leur propos je
vais être très belle pour permettre à
tous mes collègues de pouvoir s'exprimer
je rebondis sur ce que disait ma
collègue Monique de Marco j'avais
également la question sur les contrôles
d'audience ou évoquiez monsieur Mestre
la nécessité notamment d'avoir des
outils de mesure peut-être plus
efficients est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus sur la manière dont
vous voyez les choses et l'utilité
d'avoir des audiences un peu plus un peu
plus efficiente deuxième sujet c'est sur
le taux de couverture je crois que
Madame veille vous évoqué 14 % de taux
de couverture en France notamment sur le
DAB+ alors ce que j'ai peut-être pas
très bien compris vous m'en excuserez
pardon taux d'équipement des voilà
est-ce que cela comprend par exemple
tous les équipements comme on évoquait
tout à l'heure de téléphonie de
véhicules etc etc ou pas pour mesurer un
peu l'écart qui nous reste à faire et
deuxième sujet pour le coup je crois et
je partage qui a été dit je crois qu'il
existe un véritable enjeu à la fois
démocratisation mais aussi gratuité et
de pluralisme de l'information à chaque
étape de l'évolution technologique
et pour éviter tout risque de prédation
donc ne pas laisser des gens au bord du
chemin soit par coup lié notamment à la
modernisation au changement de leur
équipement soit par aussi des problèmes
de couverture mais ça a été évoqué et
c'est ce qui nécessite et je partage
évidemment ce que vous avez dit les uns
les autres quand ça s'inscrivent sur un
temps long pour permettre justement une
couverture et plus efficiente possible
et sans passage brutal je vous remercie
oui bonjour tout le monde
quand même que de chemin parcourus parce
que
il y a quelques années encore quand on
parlait du DB plus il y avait peu
d'enthousiasme mais peut d'acteurs qui
qui
l'envisager ou en tous les cas qui le
prenait et c'est d'ailleurs le sujet
dans lequel on est maintenant c'est à
dire que ça c'est je sais pas si c'est
français mais enfin bon à chaque fois
qu'on sait que quelque chose de nouveau
va naître au lieu de mettre le paquet
parce qu'on sait que c'est ce qui
s'imposera à terme tout de suite on
évite on tergiverses et ça ça a été sur
tous les enjeux de révolution
technologique concernant le secteur des
médias la plaie en fait parce que on
souvenez-vous
souvenez-vous tous les débats
que nous on a pu avoir dans les années
2000 avant de sur l'avenir de la musique
on intergiverser ensuite sur
la vidéo à la demande sur Continue
donc là ce qui est bien déjà c'est
d'acté que tout le monde a pris on
pourrait faire la le parallèle avec les
engagements sur la transition écologique
c'est pareil tergivers c'est tout et
puis d'un coup bah ouais c'est c'est là
c'est devant nous et c'est un peu plus
difficile de le faire aussi brutalement
le dos au mur donc là maintenant on est
à 50% mais je mets question
sont
sur ce qu'a dit Madame veille parce que
le diagnostic il est pour tout le monde
celui là maintenant pour passer à
l'autre phase
il y a deux problèmes à régler
qui sont
le problème de cette transition aucune
radio avec une audience sérieuse ne peut
aller plus loin
si la couverture
n'approche pas la quasi-totalité y
compris en termes publicitaire même 70%
posera un problème parce que les 30%
manquants c'est ce qui fait l'équilibre
d'une radio et
même sa survie donc
c'est l'accélération aujourd'hui qui
peut
régler régler le problème donc le
problème du coup
et là comment aller
comment aider à partir du moment où on
sait que il y a un problème de coût très
important
et là si l'État est dans l'innovation
dans ces priorités d'investissement
industriel et je parle pas le
saupoudrage pour aider des médias la
presse c'est tout dans les projets de
modernisation industrielle dans les
visions globales pour que notre pays
soit à la pointe il doit y avoir là
quelque chose de dit de fait
très fort bon voilà c'est
une question et est-ce que vous partagez
ce diagnostic qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour chacun pour le pour la question
pour vous pour le service public est-ce
que vous attendez de plus mais aussi
pour les radios qui ont pignon sur rue
après il y a le problème des
concentrations parce que si un confort
j'ai on a remarqué avec le président
Lafont dans notre commission d'enquête
que bon
ça existe dans la FM
mais
dans le DAB aussi
de façon il y a trois je pense grand
es entreprises ont été qui dominent
quasiment l'essentiel et c'est aussi
probablement lié au coup parce que cette
diversité la diversité c'est aussi qu'on
s'est accessible au plus grand nombre
je veux une poser une question précise
pour conclure à au président de la
il nous a dit un jour je compte sur le
Sénat pour le développement du DAB alors
bon comme on n'est pas on n'est pas le
gouvernement
nous ne sommes pas un fonds de soutien
avec de l'argent et pour faire des
chèques je veux qu'il précise sa pensée
qu'est-ce qu'il attend du Sénat nous on
légifère c'est-à-dire en termes de
législation c'est ça comme ça que je
l'ai compris que que pensez-vous que
l'on peut faire pour pour développer le
la le DAB pardon et pour et pour
répondre à votre préoccupation Sylvie
Robert
oui merci monsieur le Président merci à
toutes et à tous pour vos interventions
alors arrivons à la dernière beaucoup de
questions étaient posées je vais ne pas
revenir sur l'importance de la radio du
DAB et de ses vertus vous l'avez
vraiment bien énoncé l'importance d'une
forme de planification et je j'insiste
là dessus qui permettrait vraiment que
on a accentue pas les fractures sociales
et territoriales parce que derrière
c'est aussi cela
pour notamment passer la transition on
voit bien que les leviers sont multiples
alors
il touche des modèles économiques et
touche des acteurs très différents des
constructeurs des distributeurs des
opérateurs
il touche aussi l'observation on va dire
de l'évolution des usages vous en avez
parlé président de la recommande on a
parlé mais c'est quand même un point
absolument essentiel moi j'ai deux
questions est-ce que ce livre blanc dont
le président de la com a parlé
va venir en tout cas observer tout ça à
qui va-t-il s'adresser ce livre blanc
dans quel dans quel calendrier parce que
on voit bien que derrière
il y a aussi des nécessités d'aide
publique avec des leviers très
différents ça va être des leviers
fiscaux des leviers via la subvention
dans la on en a eu le 30 millions sur le
PLFR 2020 a été de celui-là donc moi
j'aimerais bien avoir des précisions sur
ce livre blanc et enfin une petite
question mais qui
est importante et l'outre-mer est-ce que
c'est en tout cas la question
ultra-marine est aussi présente dans vos
réflexions voilà merci
Sonia de la pauvreté
oui merci monsieur le Président
moi j'ai des questions qui sont
complémentaires
est revenu plusieurs fois la question de
la de la réception et donc le matériel
en fait qui va chez chez l'usager chez
le celui qui écoute la radio
est-ce qu'il y a eu une étude précise de
marché et prospective sur l'évolution de
la part de l'accès par le numérique par
le d'un pod dab et par le hertzien
puisque dans les évolutions évidemment
comportementales il y a l'utilisation de
matériel multi-usage comme les
smartphones par exemple et là pour le
coup
on n'achète pas un accès à la radio pure
quelque part quand on investit dans le
matériel on a on accède à beaucoup
d'autres choses donc comment une
stratégie digitale peut-être
clairement simplement de façon moderne
s'intégrer dans cette dans ces nouveaux
usages et vous avez évoqué un véhicule
législatif pour imposer est-ce que dans
les pays où cela s'est développé il y a
déjà eu un il y a eu besoin d'un
véhicule législatif
quel est-il s'il y a eu besoin ou est-ce
qu'ils s'en sont passés et dans ce cas
là quel est le blocage français par
rapport à ces pays si jamais eux n'ont
pas eu besoin de véhicules législatif et
puis le deuxième question
se rapproche de celle de de ma collègue
Sylvie Robert c'est la question on a il
a été dit maintien d'un média radio
libre simple d'accès gratuit je pense
qu'on souscrit tous parfaitement à cet
objectif
la liberté éditoriale d'information mais
aussi la diversité d'information
c'est-à-dire l'absence de concentration
et finalement de quelques filtres qui
décident de la de ce qui est diffusé et
de ce de l'information à laquelle accède
les auditeurs
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président je vais
juste interdire sur un seul point parce
que beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
notamment pas les intervenants mais
aussi par mes excellents collègues
je veux dire simplement sur la soubriété
parce que ça a été évoqué par certains
d'entre vous aujourd'hui
l'AFM est énergivore donc alors qu'on
parle de restriction
nous préconise de porter des cols rouler
en étant l'éclairage public la nuit là
je pense qu'il y a peut-être aussi des
économies de échelle à pouvoir faire
donc c'est pour ça est-ce que on vote
actuellement beaucoup de textes pour
accélérer certaines choses au niveau de
l'énergie est-ce que là ça serait pas
aussi une des raisons pour accélérer la
mise en place du diabète plus
et enfin dernière intervenant de
Catherine Morin de Sailly merci
président une question assez courte
compte tenu de la difficulté qui il y a
eu à faire avancer le dossier de la
modernisation de la TNT lors des
derniers débats au Parlement en tout cas
le peu d'allant la mise de l'époque
était dans une Bachelot sur ce dossier
il est permis de s'interroger sur
l'engagement du ministère sur ce dossier
également du DAB plus finalement les
dossiers sont pas les mêmes mais c'est
assez comparable dans la démarche besoin
de modification législatives besoin de
moyens importants donc pourriez-vous
nous dire en l'état quels sont aux uns
et aux autres vos discussions avec le
ministère est-ce que vous sentez du
répondant et la nécessité de faire
avancer ce dossier moi je pense qu'il
faut le faire avancer l'explorer parce
que il en va comme vous l'avez très bien
rappelé de l'avenir d'un média
extrêmement populaire
extrêmement
important qui doit aussi s'adapter aux
nouveaux usages donc j'ai voilà un enjeu
extrêmement fort vous avez aussi rappelé
je crois que c'est Sylvie qui rappelait
que ce média est porté par un secteur
extrêmement puissant
qu'elle a si sensible qui suit de la
musique
quels sont les attentes dans le domaine
de la musique alors musique bien sûr de
patrimoine et de création musique
également actuelle et musique diverses
parce que on a souvent
regretté au sein de notre commission à
chaque fois que nous avions à débattre
des différents comes que la télévision
portait assez peu la musique donc on
compte beaucoup sur la radio pour
exposer les nouveaux talents pour
exposer les oeuvres francophones
pour aussi exposer la vie musicale qui
est très riche de par le nombre de
formations qu'il y a dans nos dans notre
pays donc quels sont les attentes est-ce
que c'est une nouvelle technologie en
somme sont très attendues parce que
elles permettent aussi une meilleure
qualité une plus grande accessibilité de
tous à la culture voilà tout le monde
peut passer au spectacle et la radio
fait partie vraiment des médiums voilà
deux questions assez précises et merci
d'y répondre
je vais vous laisser vous répartir vous
saisir des questions sur lesquelles vous
souhaitez répondre peut-être monsieur le
Président de la recommande si vous
voulez commencer
merci monsieur le Président d'avoir la
gentillesse de vous tourner vers moi
pour ouvrir le bal des réponses je vais
essayer de
la globaliser ma réponse alors je
partirai peut-être de la question de
David Assouline
je crains d'avoir le privilège de l'âge
dans cette dans cette assemblée donc
ce privilège permet d'avoir un regard
rétrospectif ce qu'il a dit n'est pas
totalement faux je me souviens d'avoir
vécu très très directement tous les
débats qui qui entouraient la TNT qui
ont entouré la TNT pendant de très très
nombreuses années je ne citerai pas des
propos de certains grands présidents
d'entreprises du Vésuve public dont
certains sont encore en fonction et qui
me battent sur le thème de privilège de
l'âge mais le lancement de la TNT ça a
été quand même une très très longue
aventure et si
au sommet de l'État en particulier à
l'époque où je servais le président de
la République on n'avait pas mis son
poids pour le lancement de la TNT elle
n'aurait jamais vu le jour donc ça a
pris beaucoup de temps le DAB a vécu
exactement la même circuit on a eu les
mêmes blocages j'ai presque dire pour
les mêmes raisons
et je déblocage a fini par se faire et
donc maintenant il faut tout faire pour
puisque ce point est acquis faire en
sorte qu'on puisse le déployer deuxième
élément de réponse à plusieurs questions
qui ont été évoquées l'une des feuilles
de route consubstantielle à la voie de
86 vous le savez c'est le pluralisme
c'est vraiment le fil rouge de
l'ensemble de l'action du régulateur au
sens de la pluralité des opérateurs et
le secteur de la radio on a une parfaite
illustration on a un paysage d'une
diversité une densité qui est
spectaculaire en France plus de 1000
radio je le rappelle c'est considérable
des radios nationales des radios locales
des radios publics des radios privées
des radios musicales des radios
associatives et cette feuille de route
qui vaut pour la FM depuis la libération
de la bande alpham depuis les années
80-80 elle vaut aussi pour les ABC donc
dans notre logique d'appel à candidature
auquel nous sommes tenus et dans les
choix que le régulateur fait il veille
très attentivement à maintenir ses
équilibres j'ai bien entendu ce que
Madame banquet madame veille on dit tout
à l'heure sur le fait que ceux qui
occupent aujourd'hui au premier chef la
bande FM devait trouver naturellement
leur phase leur place de façon
prioritaire sur le sur le DAB+ nous
sommes très attentifs à préserver cet
équilibre qui tue vraiment une richesse
pour notre paysage de visuel de même
qu'on veille là aussi je réponds aux
questions qui nous sont posées à
l'équilibre de traitement des
territoires nationaux j'ai expliqué les
raisons pour lesquelles on était parti
des grands métropoles des grands axes
routiers pour ensuite couvrir l'ensemble
des territoires et notamment des
territoires moins denses ça vaut pour
l'outre-mer je le dis
à la question qui m'a été posée nous
nous avons lancé sur sur ce volet là une
expérimentation qui est maintenant en
cours en Martinique je me rendrai
prochainement aux Antilles pour regarder
ce point de façon plus spécifique
vous l'avez tous dit on l'a tous dit il
y a un vrai sujet de communication il
est prioritaire aujourd'hui c'est
évident
le cycle DAB+ n'est probablement pas le
plus heureux notion de radio numérique
par probablement beaucoup plus je suis
pas sûr que la TNT tous les Français
sachent exactement ce que le site peut
signifier mais en tout cas votre
observation est juste et aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'on a la chance d'avoir une
association de promotion du DAB qui
existe et les récentes il faut qu'elle
déploie ses ailes il faut qu'elle
déploie son action et ça ça dépend de
vous les acteurs c'est quand la TNT
quand on avait créé l'association pour
le lancement de la TNT c'est les acteurs
compris les choses en main et qui ont
mené les campagnes de sensibilisation
d'information des Français il y a que
vous qui pouvez le faire avec vos
antennes et par le biais de cette
association quitte bien sûr à ce que
l'État puisse l'accompagner
avec ses propres outils pour ses propres
moyens financiers pour vous aider dans
cette dans cette action
sur les procédures
la longueur des procédures n'est pas
liée exclusivement faudrait quand même
insister sur ce point sur le cadrage
juridique peut-être été mon expression
était peut-être pas totalement juge il y
a effectivement une longueur de
procédure qui est liée au fait que
toutes les attributions de fréquence en
radio comme en télévision
vous savez qu'on a un petit dossier en
cours en matière de télévision sur des
renouvellements de fréquence
ces procédures d'appel à candidature
sont longues mais c'est elle et elle
seule qui permettent de garantir le
pluralisme auquel vous êtes tous attaché
mais derrière ce processus d'appel à
candidature et d'attribution des
fréquences il y a aussi tout le travail
que les opérateurs eux-mêmes doivent
mener création d'un multiplex qui est
dans le multiplexe comment on gère le
multiplexe derrière la constitution du
multiplex le déploiement des émetteurs
ou est-ce qu'on positionne les émetteurs
et c'est un travail très très fin en
courant en ce moment sur beaucoup de
beaucoup de sites et donc ce volet
technique qui suit les procédures
d'appel à candidature explique aussi la
longueur des procédures et donc par
rapport à la feuille de route de l'arcom
que nous avons accéléré et on est en
avance de phase d'ailleurs par rapport
aux propres calendriers qu'on s'était
fixé puisque on pensait atteindre 40%
fin 22 et qu'on est au delà 45% avec
l'objectif cette année d'atteindre 50 je
pense
pas le moment enfin c'est pas sur ce
point-là me semble-t-il que
l'intervention du législateur et la et
prioritaire on a une feuille de route 24
c'est demain en étant 23 24 c'est après
demain
donc je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
modifier ce cadre-là par contre il y a
quelques points sur lequel
l'intervention du législateur me paraît
utile je l'ai évoqué sur l'équipement
sur la sécurisation des postes de radio
sur les sur les voitures sur la question
des mentions légales et sur la sujet de
l'accompagnement financier monsieur
Assouline puisque vous m'avez posé la
question je pense que le Parlement a
joué un rôle à jouer je l'avais dit en
son temps et je le redis notamment dans
dans la fixation des crédits du Fe du f
du Fonds de soutien d'expression
radiophonique le fseer pardon
c'est un petit budget 30 millions
d'euros par an comme hors de grandeur et
chiffres ont été cités par les acteurs
ici présents
je révoquerai pas le déficit du budget
de l'État en tout cas c'est pas le sujet
qui nous rassemble aujourd'hui qui est
susceptible de menacer gravement les
finances publiques
donc si accompagnement il peut y avoir
il peut aussi y avoir un accompagnement
sur ce sur ce point là
c'est réglementaire c'est le
réglementaire et législatif j'ai évoqué
sur les obligations
sur les sujets de déploiement
d'équipements donc l'obligation d'avoir
la puce d'arbre dans les récepteurs
notre dès l'entrée de gamme la
sécurisation des
autoradios dans tous les véhicules
pour sécuriser ce point là la question
des mentions les gars mais je pensais
aussi effectivement la question de
l'accompagnement budgétaire via le fond
de soutien à l'expression radiophonique
voilà je vais pas mobiliser toutes les
réponses parce que je pense que
d'autres souhaitent intervenir sur ce
point madame banquet
la vie de Monsieur Assouline sur le
besoin de préserver la couverture de la
population ou la beaucoup dit pour nos
radios c'est évidemment on protège nos
audiences on protège nos chiffres
d'affaires mais évidemment il faut pas
qu'on perde des auditeurs lors de ce
passage sur la concentration aussi en
termes de couverture les groupes privés
ne peuvent pas dépasser 160 millions
d'auditeurs donc ça garantit le
pluralisme je ne veux pas m'opposer à
mon ami civil Weil mais je crois que sur
sur la couverture vous n'avez pas de
seuil vous n'avez pas de seuil imposé
sur la musique aussi peut-être mais je
vais peut-être pas être les seuls c'est
vrai que la radio et le dernier endroit
où on écoute la musique gratuitement à
la différence des plateformes qui sont
beaucoup moins réguliers que nous en
particulier sur les quotas donc je crois
rock les levure mais c'est vrai que on a
besoin de vous on a besoin de vous sur
ce sur nous soutenir sur cette loi de de
2016 qui a été toujours ci avec le
plafonnement des rotations des titres
francophones et que nous on a besoin là
dessus d'aide sur les sur les quotas on
en a beaucoup parlé mais je profite de
cette tribune pour le redire et pour
redire que la radio est la seule le seul
endroit où on diffuse de la musique
gratuitement voilà
merci de 3 réponse complémentaires à ce
qui a été dit le nom d'abord on parlait
tout à l'heure de RNT qui avait été le
premier la première dénomination des AB
plus c'est une marque partagée à
l'échelle de la planète et donc on
serait un peu isolé si demain on
changeait de nom quant à cette offre
donc je pense qu'on louait et on compose
avec le public sous la propretera quand
on lui quand on quand on lui en parlera
et et je veux y croire pour ce qui est
des mesures d'audience les questions
étaient posées tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui effectivement on peut pas
faire la distinction entre entre les
différents canaux de réception
Mediamétrie travail on devrait accélérer
à ces éléments dans les dans les
prochains mois ou les prochaines années
les prochains mois plus
vraisemblablement donc c'est une
information dont on a besoin si on était
effectivement aujourd'hui certains que
le DAB+ représentait déjà 20% de notre
audience on pourrait plus du tout
considérer que ce soit une option donc
attendant ces éléments avec avec
attention la concentration si vous
parliez en fait d'acteurs régionaux qui
sont principalement
je réponds à la question de de
claudessouline
les radios ont souvent été les nôtres en
tout cas créés par des passionnés il y a
40 ans et après 40 ans parfois même dans
un couple la passion pour un peu
s'estomper donc certains de nos
opérateurs historiques
passent la main et effectivement des
opérateurs nationaux enfin de grands
opérateurs régionaux aujourd'hui peuvent
s'étendre et racheter des radios qui
avait été créés à l'époque mais il y a
pas il y a pas de je ne vois pas moi
trois acteurs principaux qui ceux qui
seraient aujourd'hui intéressés plus que
d'autres par le fait d'étendre leur zone
en FM ou en DAB+ et puis effectivement
les les les questions liées à la musique
sont central
quel est le problème auquel la radio
dans sa globalité se heurte aujourd'hui
c'est le fait surtout que la jeune
génération se détourne de de ce que nous
produisons et on l'a pas dit encore mais
si le DAB plus permet en particulier de
répondre à cette à cette question
importante là il faut que nous soyons
diffusés partout par tous les canaux
pour que la jeune génération qui habitué
à écouter des sons compressés se disent
aussi que la diffusion analogique peut
appartenir pour un moment appartenir au
passé et que le diab+ et les sondes
aujourd'hui donc la jeunesse c'est
vraiment le l'un des objectifs centraux
notre audience de demain évidemment et
celle qui aujourd'hui nous fait défauts
donc travaillons également à les
convaincre en matière de contenu et
aussi en matière de device et de et de
et de mode de diffusion
merci monsieur le Président sur la
question de savoir quel est le besoin
que nous avons tous aujourd'hui moi je
répondrai très simplement on a besoin de
visibilité c'est à dire que on voit bien
tous qu'on a un enjeu on ne veut pas
fragiliser le média donc on veut que la
transition soit suffisamment longue et
bien menée pour pas perdre d'auditeur
mais plus elle va être longue plus ça va
être coûteux or on a tous fait le
constat que il y a eu beaucoup
d'hésitations sur le fait de lancer
cette technologie pourquoi parce que
aucun acteur n'a économiquement intérêt
à investir massivement s'il ne sait pas
si sert jusqu'au bout donc en fait la
vraie question c'est quel est le
calendrier dans lequel l'adoption de
cette nouvelle technologie ira à son
terme quel calendrier dans lequel elle
viendra se substituer à l'AFM je pense
que le premier besoin de tous les
acteurs économiques c'est celui-là parce
que c'est ce qui fait que tout le monde
a des rafra franchement il pourra fonder
aussi sa stratégie ses décisions
financières
sur cette question là je rappelle que
Radio France à chercher à justement
donner aussi des signaux à l'ensemble du
secteur sur cette question là moi dès
2018 c'est d'ailleurs ma première
audition devant à l'époque le CSA quand
je me présentais comme candidat à Radio
France j'avais pris l'engagement qu'on
irait très franchement dans le DAB+ et
qu'on le soutiendrait ce qu'on a fait
sans équivoque tout au long de ces
dernières années j'appellerai aussi que
le service public a éteint ces ondes
longues et saison de moyenne plutôt en
avance par rapport à l'ensemble du
secteur ayant encore le souci de donner
des signaux positifs que les économies
faites d'ailleurs à cette occasion a été
rendu en contribuable en 2015 et 2016 à
l'occasion des plans d'économie
successifs qu'a pu faire Radio France
pour améliorer l'efficience de la
dépense publique dont nous avons la
responsabilité et ce qu'on continuera
évidemment de faire
dans les conditions cette visibilité
elle doit s'accompagner aussi je pense
de certains accompagnements législatifs
très bien rappelés par le président de
la recom
la présence dans les voitures est
indispensable pourquoi elle est
indispensable parce que on voit
qu'aujourd'hui avec le développement des
tableaux de bord connectés les
constructeurs automobiles ont tendance à
sous-traiter au Gafa la
l'info tellement au sein des véhicules
donc aujourd'hui c'est Google c'est
Apple c'est Amazon qui opère ses
tableaux de bord connectés qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire et donc là ça rejoint
d'ailleurs une question qui a été posée
par la signatrice Catherine Morin dessei
sur la musique ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que peut-être qu'un jour les
automobilistes quand ils rentreront dans
leur voiture et elles auront Amazon
musique Apple music YouTube directement
accessible qu'ils auront pas ou en tout
cas très difficilement accès aux radios
nationales alors quand on sait le rôle
qu'on les acteurs de la radio nationale
pour soutenir notamment la diversité
musicale la scène française on a une
scène musicale française aussi forte
aujourd'hui en France c'est bien parce
qu'il y a des acteurs de la radio pour
soutenir l'affaire connaître l'affaire
durer la rendre visible donc je pense
que pour cette souveraineté culturelle
aussi cette question la souveraineté
culturelle le fait de préserver le média
radio et ses conditions de distribution
c'est une condition qui est essentielle
enfin pour répondre à l'anticipation sur
les conditions de technologie
nous sommes réunis ensemble avec
l'ensemble des autres acteurs privés
monsieur Schalke y a fait référence dans
Radio Player Radio Player il se trouve
que c'est une technologie européenne qui
en plus à cette particularité d'être
hybride c'est à dire qu'elle passe du
DAB à l'épée et c'est bien l'évolution
de la radio je pense que son évolution
dans les années c'est bien sûr des modes
de réception qui soient hybrides c'est
le fait que les différents entre les
différents appareils il y a un suivi une
continuité et c'est bien là-dessus qu'il
faut que nous travaillons tous ensemble
col effectivement et une réflexion comme
celle qui est proposée par le président
de larkom doit nous permettre d'avoir un
coût d'avance aussi stratégique sur ce
qu'on veut faire ensemble pour justement
continuer à faire en sorte que le média
radio soit moderne soit attractif et
soit diffusé dans les meilleures
conditions possibles de simplicité pour
le public qu'on veut continuer à toucher
parce que sinon qu'est-ce qui fera il
écoutera YouTube chez lui directement
dans sa voiture sans avoir pu passer par
la radio donc je pense que l'enjeu de
fond derrière c'est celui-ci et qu'il
faut que l'ensemble du secteur soit uni
derrière cet enjeu là
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
je ne sais pas si c'est une question au
calendrier
de toute façon je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord et le défi du DAB il faut le
surmonter il faut le surmonter
maintenant parce que ça a commencé il y
a eu tergiversation et maintenant il
s'agit d'un défi qui n'est plus un défi
technologique qui n'est plus un défi de
planification mais qui est un défi
économique et voir industriel
donc la question est-ce que c'est une
question de calendrier non le calendrier
il est là il est il est finalement il
nous est guidé il est guidé par la
planification de leur come que je le
répète est tout à fait satisfaisante la
question est pas là des interrogations
subsistent sur certaines zones blanches
ça se résoudra mais le calendrier est là
il est bien il a démarré depuis
longtemps maintenant la question c'est
celle de Monsieur le Président d'une
d'un signal politique
comme exactement et vous l'avez soulevé
exactement comme après les tergiversales
les 8 ou 10 ans de tergiversations sur
la TNT est-ce que c'est une question de
nom de marque dabad RNT j'en sais rien
bon c'est à réfléchir le cas échéant
c'est pas un obstacle ça si on est fait
comme le dit Christophe chalk c'est une
c'est un nom
unanimement porté au plan européen il y
a aucun souci là-dessus il faut
maintenir le nom d'arbre par contre il
faut un signal politique fort ce signal
politique nécessite
incontestablement
un soutien de la puissance publique
c'est pas forcément un soutien
massif économique le président Chirac
avait provisionné 150 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui 150 millions d'euros on
regardait pas de relance c'est pas grand
chose je sais que c'est beaucoup
monsieur le Président de la com mais ça
se ça se travaille on va dire sur
d'autres économies qui peuvent être
réalisées donc en effet la question
c'est celle de la volonté politique donc
du ciel politique et c'est une chaîne ne
peut venir que du gouvernement et
évidemment du Parlement c'est pour ça
que à mon sens votre rôle est essentiel
j'en terminerai par un petit mot sur les
radios pour quelques secondes c'est vrai
que les radios locales associatives sont
partiellement subventionnés de par la
loi article article 29 et article 80 de
la loi de 86
c'est vrai que nous avons entamé d'ores
et déjà et ça aboutit des discussions
sur soutient particulier à la double
diffusion qui je le répète est pour 200
des nôtres des gens entamés depuis
plusieurs années mais il s'agit de 200
euros par mois je le répète monsieur le
Président il s'agit de 200 euros par
mois pour les opérateurs c'est ça reste
ça reste un petit peu faible donc je
tiens à vous préciser que notre demande
de soutien financier logistique pour les
radios associatives et je remercie le
président de la comédieure l'ensemble
des éditeurs ici présents de ne pas
avoir fait obstacle à ce type de soutien
supplémentaire il reste limité au regard
du défi que nous devons tous relever et
ensemble je vous remercie
de me donner la parole c'était juste
pour répondre à deux questions qui n'ont
pas trouvé de de réponse pour pour
l'instant et commencer par pardonnez-moi
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire si
bille sur le fait que il importe quand
même de bien comprendre que personne ici
n'imagine que le DAB plus c'est l'alpha
et l'oméga du succès de la radio de
demain c'est un des piliers un des
éléments extrêmement importants et ce
qui est important c'est que la radio
soit présente partout où il y a des
usages donc par rapport à une question
qui a été posée tout à l'heure sur le
rapport entre l'écoutant en
IP FM et dab alors entre FM et dab il
faut qu'on puisse
marquer les signaux FM et DAB pour
pouvoir mesurer les audiences et voir
dans quelle proportion les uns et les
autres écoutent l'AFM et le DAB en
revanche on regarde de très près le
rapport entre l'écoute en numérique en
IP et et celle en hertzien
d'abord il faut quand même se rappeler
que la radio linéaire représente
aujourd'hui 56% de l'usage total de
l'audio c'est à dire qu'il comprend
également les plateformes de streaming
musical qui comprend également l'écoute
des podcasts et donc on voit bien que la
radio est toujours la radio linéaire est
toujours extrêmement puissante et
ensuite dans le rapport dans l'écoute de
la radio linéaire entre le hertzien et
l'IP et donc le le internet on est
toujours dans 80% de l'écoute de la
radio linéaire qui se fait en hertzien
donc on voit que ça reste également
extrêmement puissant et on comprend bien
en quoi le DA plus
et le hertzien d'une manière générale
reste au-delà de tous les avantages qui
ont été évoqués un point extrêmement
important pour le dynamisme de la radio
ça c'était pour répondre à une première
question et la deuxième question qui
portait sur la sobriété énergétique
en fait la raison elle est très simple
les émetteurs consomment beaucoup moins
d'énergie à diffuser le DA plus que que
la FM puisque la spécificité de la
technologie du DA plus c'est de
permettre de d'en coquiller si j'ose
dire dans un seul et même signal dans
sur une seule et même fréquence 13
signaux de radio différents donc là où
aujourd'hui on analogie que vous avez
très fréquences pour 13 radios avec le
DA plus vous avez 13 radios pour une
seule fréquence donc on consomme
beaucoup moins d'énergie
je serai encore très rapide juste je
rejoins Sybille sur la visibilité en
revanche pas de visibilité au risque
d'être un petit peu assistante sans aide
la Radio France est aidé enfin et
financée par l'État les radios
associatifs
et les radios privés on doit se financer
sur nos recettes et on l'a dit tout à
l'heure les recettes
ne sont pas extensibles et surtout en ce
moment donc c'est vrai que je vais
conclure par ça les aides et
l'engagement de l'État est essentiel
pour les radios privés merci de votre
attention merci dernière question
monsieur le Président Monsieur de la com
puisque vous avez annoncé le livre blanc
la possibilité de faire un livre blanc
sous quel calendrier ce livre blanc
pourrait être élaboré parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il pourrait répondre à un
certain nombre de questions qui ont été
posées ce matin et en termes de
calendrier de bascule éventuellement
d'accompagnement
je profitais de cette de cette table
ronde pour pour faire cette proposition
vous êtes toujours demandeur de
proposition dans ce genre d'enceinte
donc si elle fait qu'on s'insuse auprès
des uns et des autres également des
services de l'État puisque bien
évidemment ça intéresse aussi les tas
qui était aussi évoqué à l'occasion de
cette table ronde on pourrait se mettre
en ordre de marche
vers le directeur qui je vois Pali
je me souviens d'une réunion dans la
jeunesse puisqu'on évoquait le président
Chirac à l'hôtel de ville de Paris une
réunion où il y avait une batterie de
directeur qui était présent et une fois
n'était pas coutume c'était extrêmement
courtois le président a piqué un coup de
sang sur un dossier qui était
complètement en carafé et après il y a
un mot que je ne prononcerai pas dans
cet enceinte parce qu'il pourrait
choquer certaines oreilles qui a fait
cette bêtise je dirais pour traduire son
propos il se tourne vers le secrétaire
général à l'Hôtel de Ville le secrétaire
général lui-même se tourne vers le
directeur qui est à côté qui se tourne
vers le chef de service qui se tourne
vers le chemin de bureau donc on a vu
toutes les têtes tournées là je me
tourne vers le directeur
comme il se doit voilà
donc tout ça pour dire que
voilà on pourrait s'y mettre ça demande
d'entendre l'ensemble des l'ensemble des
acteurs ça prend ça prend un petit peu
de temps
en tout cas on essaierait de conclure
assez rapidement mais l'idée serait
vraiment d'entendre tous les points de
vue d'essayer de bâtir des scénarios de
voir bien toutes les questions qui
s'opposent et d'éclairer la visibilité
qui a été évoquée par la présidente
veille
semestre
lancement lancement premier semestre
je pense qu'il faut il faut compter
quand même quelques mois pour entendre
un peu tout le monde
d'ici la première
mesdames et messieurs merci beaucoup de
vos participations et des précisions et
des éclairages que vous avez donné je
pense que cette table ronde DT utile en
tout cas je sais qu'elle était assez
attendue bien sûr par les sénatrices et
les sénateurs mais au-delà parce qu'il
était nécessaire et
utile que nous parlions de ce sujet
peut-être plus on a bien perçu à travers
vos interventions respectives les enjeux
qui sont derrière et évidemment la
commission culture
éducation et communication du Sénat est
très
attentive à vous accompagner sur ces
enjeux stratégiques pour le secteur de
la radio merci beaucoup